meine damen und herren liebe gemeinde
vor dieser woche war ich sage ich ganz
ehrlich kein großer kirchgänger aber
wenn man selber leibhaftiger zeuge eines
wunders geworden ist die union hat ihren
obergrenzen streit beigelegt doch zu
meinen lebzeiten halleluja preiset den
horst freunde cdu und csu ich zitiere
streben einen richtwert von 200.000
flüchtlinge an
es sei denn es kommen mehr das heißt ja
es ist
rewe zwischen cdu und csu das heißt sie
haben sich auf original gar nichts
geheim ich ja und die cats im lande
rufen zwei jahre streit zu so einen
idioten kompromiss warum erst jetzt
ich aber sage euch alles hat seine zeit
und gestern war diese zeit
ganz genau alles hat seine zeit nur die
herrschaft merkels während ewiglich so
steht es im buchhandel meine wirklich
alberner schaukampf führen nichts und
vor allem halten den damit das einzige
thema am köcheln dass die afg hat das
einzige ohne not ich möchte beiden
herrschaften spontan eine af der
ehrenmitgliedschaft verliehen herzlichen
glückwunsch wirklich jetzt zehn stunden
sitzung dafür
überlegen sie doch mal was man da alles
schaffen könnte in zehn stunden was weiß
ich wenn mein auto von köln nach
leverkusen fahren zum beispiel zehn
stunden
so here berechtigte frage und sehr
schlagfertige reaktionen müssen sie sich
nicht eingestehen dass sie in diesem
punkt beide schlicht und einfach versagt
haben die frage beantwortet sich von
selbst
wie wäre es denn zur abwechslung mal mit
stundenlangen krisensitzungen zu themen
wie in altersarmut pflegenotstand oder
bezahlbarer wohnraum
wer ein fest seehofer kriegt zwar keine
obergrenze aber dafür eine zahl
toll ich finde selbst das zu viel hätte
man anders lösen können unbegrenzt
obergrenze obergrenzen obergrenze
obergrenze obergrenze obergrenze
ja
denn nur so lernt erst die entscheidende
frage lautet jetzt natürlich wie geht es
weiter mit der cdu merkels partei ist
inhaltlich komplett entkernt und sehnt
sich nach frischen gesichtern nach jens
spahn zum beispiel dem neuen shooting
star ja der hippe hoffnungsträger wurde
gerade erst bei der jungen union
gefeiert und reich beschenkt es gibt in
unserem land noch viele harte nüsse wie
wir politisch knacken müssen und als
kleines symbol und fleisch für die
echten kleinen nüsse diesen am 8
[Applaus]
was für ein scheiß gesenkt
in dem moment wo er kleine nüsse sagt
merkt er selber dass das verbockt hat
insgesamt wird die union natürlich
eindeutig konservativer das zeigt vor
allem der nagelneue zehn punkte plan der
csu ja da stehen wirklich nur geniale
setzte drin wir zum beispiel punkt fünf
bürgerliche politik ist sich gerade auch
für die anliegen der kleinen leute ein
zu spreizen steht also ein spreizen
klinke schmerzhaft aber naja
die csu kämpft jedenfalls für kleine
leute und fragt fühlen sich die menschen
die so genannten kleinen leute
angesprochen aber wie die kleinen leute
in deutschland empfinden viele
sogenannte kleine leute früher würde man
sagen die kleinen leute die frage wie
empfinden viele der sogenannten führen
dabei ist die kleine leute sind so
kleine leute haben wenig geld ja genau
die csu die den mindestlohn bis aufs
blut bekämpft hat die die
erbschaftssteuer für firmenerben bis
heute sabotiert spreizt sich jetzt für
kleine leute schön
passend zum spreizen auch punkt 10 denn
da steht ernsthaft konservativ ist
wieder sexy zitat ende erster nein
zweitens hat in münchen tatsächlich
gerade die erste konservative
tabledance-bar aufgemacht freunde tanzen
nur csu-abgeordnete an der stange die
ladies flippen aus und kein aufpreis
kommt er zu dir nach hause und wäscht
ein auto die geile sau
denn für sexyness gibt es keine
obergrenze und damit kommen wir auch
schon zum entscheidenden punkt nummer 7
zitat gesunder patriotismus und liebe
zur heimat sind wichtig absolut
allerdings sagen dass gerade so ziemlich
alle deutschen parteien
man könnte meinen die etablierte politik
entdeckt quasi das wort heimat